ASSEMBLY MEMBER RADIUS NOTICES
THE ABSENCE OF A QUORUM THE
SERGEANTS AT ARMS WILL PREPARE
THE CHAMBER AND BRING IN THE
ABSENT MEMBERS AND THE CLERK
WILL CALL THE ROLL.
AGUIAR-CURRY ARAMBULA BARRICADE
HIM BENNETT BERMAN BIGELOW
BLOOM BOERNER HORVATH BRIAN
BURKE ALONE RUBIO CERVANTES
CHAU CHEN CHIU CHOI COOLEY
COOPER CUNNINGHAM DALY DALY
DAVIES FLORA FONG FRAZIER
FRIEDMAN GABRIEL GALLAGHER
CRISTINA GARCIA EDUARDO GARCIA
GIPSON GONZALEZ GREAT GRAYSON
HOLDEN IRWIN JONES SAWYER KALRA
KILEY LACKEY LEAD LEVINE LOW
MAIENSCHEIN MATHIS MAYES
MCCARTY MEDINA MULLIN
MURATSUCHI THE SYRIAN WHEN
O'DONNELL PATTERSON
PETRIE-NORRIS CORK CORK SILVA
RAMOS RAY IS THREE OF US
ROBERT RIVAS RODRIGUEZ RUBIO
SALAS SANTIAGO C. R. TO SMITH.
STONE THING RELATIVE IS BE
APPROVED WHILE VOEPEL WALDRON
WARD WEBER WICKS. WOOD MISTER
SPEAKER.
MEMBERS OF A QUORUM IS
PRESENT. A QUORUM IS PRESENT IN
THE ASSEMBLY. WE ASK OUR GUESTS
AND VISITORS IN THE REAR
CHAMBER. AND IN THE GALLERY. TO
PLEASE STAND FOR THE PRAYER.
DAYS PRAYER WE OFFERED BY OUR
ASSEMBLY CHAPLAIN IMAM YASIR
KHAN THE MONEY AFTER. IN THE
NAME OF GOD. THE MOST GRACIOUS
THE MOST MERCIFUL. THE VOICES
OF THE POOR AND THE HUNGRY. ARE
NOT TOO STRONG OR TOO POWERFUL.
OFTENTIMES THEIR CRIES ARE NOT
HEARD. AND HER INFLUENCE IS NOT
MEASURED. GIVE US ALL SINCERE
AND DEEP CONCERN FOR THEIR
CONDITIONS. FOR WHAT IS A
NATION STATE OR COMMUNITY WHICH
FORGETS THE LEAST OF HIS
PEOPLE. I MEAN. TAKE YOUR MOM
YES SIR YES OUR GUESTS AND
VISITORS TO REMAIN STANDING AND
JOIN US FOR THE FLAG SALUTE
PLEASE JOIN ASSEMBLY MEMBER
DALY AS HE LEADS US IN THE
PLEDGE MISTER DALY. PLEASE JOIN
THE PLEDGE I PLEDGE ALLEGIANCE
TO THE FLAG. OF THE UNITED
STATES OF AMERICA. AND TO THE
REPUBLIC FOR WHICH IT STANDS
ONE NATION UNDER GOD.
INDIVISIBLE WITH LIBERTY AND
JUSTICE FOR ALL. THANK YOU MAY
BE SEATED. READING OF THE
PREVIOUS DAY'S JOURNAL
SACRAMENTO TUESDAY MAY FOURTH
TWENTY TWENTY ONE IS IN THE
BALLOT SEVEN AM THE ARTICLE
PASSED WITH ALMOST IN THE RIVER
SEVENTH DISTRICT ZONING TO
FOLKS WHO PROGRAM THE BEST
RECORD DAVID BOWMAN READING
ROLL CALL THE FOLLOWING PLACE
FOR MORNING ROBLES OF THE
MYSTERY IS MOVES. AND MISS
WALDRON SECONDS. AT THE READING
OF THE PRE DAY'S JOURNAL BE
DISPENSED WITH. PRESENTATIONS
OF PETITIONS THERE ARE NONE
INTRODUCTION AND REFERENCE OF
BILLS WILL BE DEFERRED. REPORTS
OF COMMITTEES WILL BE DEEMED
READ. AND AMENDMENTS DEEMED
ADOPTED. MESSAGES FROM THE
GOVERNOR THERE ARE NONE
MESSAGES FROM THE SENATE. THERE
ARE NONE. MOTIONS AND
RESOLUTIONS ABSENCES FOR THE
DAY FOR PERSONAL BUSINESS
ASSEMBLY MEMBER O'DONNELL AND
FOR ILLNESS ASSEMBLY MEMBER SAY
YOUR TOTAL. MEMBERS WHERE IT
PROCEDURAL MOTIONS. MAJORITY
LEADER RANTS YOU ARE RECOGNIZED
THANK YOU MISTER SPEAKER I
REQUEST UNANIMOUS CONSENT TO
SUSPEND ASSEMBLY RULE ONE
EIGHTEEN EIGHTY TO ALLOW
ASSEMBLY MEMBER TO HAVE HIS SON
SEATED AT HIS DESK. WITHOUT
OBJECTION SUCH SHALL BE THE
ORDER I REQUEST UNANIMOUS
CONSENT TO SUSPEND ASSEMBLY
RULE FORTY FIVE POINT FIVE TWO
ALLOWS SIMPLY MEMBER WICKS TO
SPEAK ON AND ADJOURNMENTS IN
MEMORY TODAY. AGAIN WITHOUT
OBJECTION SUCH SHALL BE THE
ORDER. PURSUANT TO ASSEMBLY
RULE NINETY SIX I REQUEST
UNANIMOUS CONSENT TO RE REFER
SB FOUR NINETEEN STERN FROM THE
NATURAL RESOURCES COMMITTEE TO
THE LABOR AND EMPLOYMENT
COMMITTEE AND THEN BACK TO THE
NATURAL RESOURCES COMMITTEE. SB
FIVE TWENTY THREE LEYVA FROM
THE HEALTH COMMITTEE TO THE
LABOR AND EMPLOYMENT COMMITTEE
AND THEN BACK TO THE HEALTH
COMMITTEE. SB SEVEN OH FIVE
WEST SO FROM THE EDUCATION
COMMITTEE TO THE LABOR AND
EMPLOYMENT COMMITTEE AND THEN
BACK TO THE EDUCATION
COMMITTEE. AND SB SIX SIX FIVE
ON BURKE FOR THE MILITARY AND
VETERANS AFFAIRS COMMITTEE. TO
THE LABOR AND EMPLOYMENT
COMMITTEE AND THEN BACK TO THE
MILITARY AND VETERANS AFFAIRS
COMMITTEE. AGAIN WITHOUT
OBJECTION SUCH SHALL BE THE
ORDER. I REQUEST UNANIMOUS
CONSENT TO SUSPEND ASSEMBLY
RULE FIFTY SIX TO ALLOW THE
FOLLOWING COMMITTEES TO NOTICE
NOTICE BILLS PENDING REFERRAL
FROM OTHER COMMITTEES TO ALLOW
THE HUMAN SERVICES COMMITTEE TO
NOTICE THE FOLLOWING BILLS FOR
THEIR HEARING ON JUNE THIRTIETH
PENDING RECEIPT. SB FOUR NINETY
SEVEN LIMóN PENDING REFERRAL
FROM BANKING AND FINANCE
COMMITTEE SB FIVE TWELVE ATKINS
PENDING REFERRAL FROM HIGHER
EDUCATION COMMITTEE AND SB FIVE
FORTY SIX WILK PENDING REFERRAL
FROM COMMUNICATIONS AND
CONVEYANCE COMMITTEE TO ALLOW
THE LABOR AND EMPLOYMENT
COMMITTEE TO NOTICE STE SB SIX
TO EIGHT ALLEN FOR THEIR
HEARING ON JUNE TWENTY SECOND.
PENDING RECEIPT FROM THE ARTS
ENTERTAINMENT SPORTS TOURISM
AND INTERNET MEDIA COMMITTEE TO
ALLOW THE TRANSPORTATION
COMMITTEE TO NOTICE SB SEVEN
NINETY STERN FOR THEIR HEARING
ON JULY FIFTH PENDING RECEIPT
FROM THE WATER PARKS AND
WILDLIFE COMMITTEE. WITHOUT
OBJECTION SUCH SHALL BE THE
ORDER. I REQUEST UNANIMOUS
CONSENT TO SUSPEND ASSEMBLY
RULE SIXTY THREE OF SEVENTY
SEVEN TO ALLOW ASSEMBLY MEMBER
TEAM TO TAKE UP AB ONE TWENTY
EIGHT TEAM TODAY WITHOUT
REFERENCE TO FILE FOR THE
PURPOSE OF CONCURRENCE IN
SENATE AMENDMENTS. WITHOUT
OBJECTION SUCH SHALL BE THE
ORDER AND MY FINAL REQUEST I
REQUEST UNANIMOUS CONSENT TO
WISH YOU AND EARLY HAPPY
BIRTHDAY FOR TOMORROW. MISTER%
FLORES WE WITHHOLDING INSTANCE
ENOUGH A ROLL CALL VOTE.
JECHEON OVERRULED. MEMBERS WE
ARE. GOING TO BUSINESS ON THE
DAILY FILE. SECOND READING
CORPORATION SENATE BILL
642-779-4318 TEN ELEVEN EIGHT
TWELVE TO SEVENTY THREE WITH
THE MEMBERS AND SENATE BILL
THREE SEVENTY EIGHT WITHIN
MINUTES. ALL BILLS WILL BE
DEEMED READ AND AMENDMENTS
DEEMED ADOPTED. MEMBERS WE ARE
GOING TO TAKE UP THE BUDGET
BILL AT THIS TIME. WITHOUT
REFERENCE TO FILE. THIS IS
ASSEMBLY BILL. ONE TWENTY
EIGHT. CORKERY SOME REAL ONE
TWENTY EIGHT BY ASSEMBLYMEMBER
TING ACCORDING TO THE STATE
BUDGET SIGNIFICANT NEARLY
BUDGET BILL MISTER KANE YOU MAY
OPEN THANK YOU MISTER SPEAKER
I'M RISING TODAY VERY PROUD TO
INTRODUCE A RECORD AND VERY
HISTORIC BUDGET. IT WAS ONLY
LAST YEAR THAT WE STOOD HERE.
BARELY A FEW MONTHS INTO OUR
COBIT PANDEMIC. WE WERE LOOKING
AT A HISTORIC FIFTY BILLION
DOLLAR DEFICIT WE REALLY
WEREN'T SURE WHAT WAS GONNA
HAPPEN TO OUR ECONOMY. WE
WEREN'T SURE HOW LONG WE WOULD
BE IN THIS PANDEMIC AND WHAT.
DEVASTATION IT MIGHT DO TO OUR
POPULATION. TO OUR BUSINESSES
TO OUR SCHOOLS TO ALL THE
VARIOUS INSTITUTIONS THAT WE
HOLD DEAR IN OUR STATE. TODAY I
AM PROUD TO RISE IN PRESENT FOR
A BUDGET. THAT IS A RECORD
BUDGET IN OUR STATE'S HISTORY.
IT IS A TWO HUNDRED AND SIXTY
SEVEN BILLION DOLLAR BUDGET A
HUNDRED NINETY FIVE BILLION
DOLLAR GENERAL FUND. A RECORD
TWENTY FIVE BILLION DOLLARS IN
RESERVE WITH THE GOAL OF A
THIRTY FIVE BILLION DOLLAR
RESERVE BY TWENTY TWENTY FOUR
TWENTY TWENTY FIVE THIS IS IN
CONTRAST TO LAST YEAR'S RESERVE
WHICH WAS ONLY FOURTEEN BILLION
DOLLARS. WE'RE PAYING OFF
ELEVEN BILLION DOLLARS IN PROP
NINETY DEFERRALS BY EIGHT POINT
ONE BILLION IN OUR SECOND ROUND
OF THE GOLDEN STATE STIMULUS.
ONE POINT FIVE BILLION IN SMALL
BUSINESS AND NONPROFIT GRANTS.
TWO BILLION DOLLARS IN SMALL
BUSINESS UNEMPLOYMENT. TAX
CREDITS FOR. TO HELP MITIGATE
THE INCREASE IN UNEMPLOYMENT
INSURANCE. THIS BUDGET THAT I'M
PRESENTING IS PART OF A ROBUST
BUDGET PROCESS EVEN DURING
COVERT WHEN MANY TIMES WE HAD
TO DO HEARINGS WITH REMOTE
PARTICIPATION. WE HAD TO DO
HEARINGS WHERE WE HAD TO WORK
AROUND- COMMITTEE SCHEDULES
WE'VE BEEN ABLE TO HOLD SIXTY
TWO BUDGET HEARINGS AND I
DISSIPATE THAT BY THE END OF
THE YEAR THAT WILL BE HAVING
UPWARDS OF ALMOST ONE HUNDRED
HEARINGS. TO DISCUSS THIS VERY
SIZEABLE INVESTMENT IN OUR
STATE. HOUSING AND HOMELESSNESS
WERE THE TOP ISSUES BEFORE WE
WENT INTO THIS PANDEMIC AND
THEY REMAIN SOME OF THE TOP
ISSUES TODAY. IN THIS BUDGET.
THIRTY EIGHT AND A HALF BILLION
DOLLARS OVER THE NEXT TWO YEARS
FOR NEW HOMELESSNESS FUNDING.
THERE'S A BILLION DOLLARS ON
GOING I THOUGHT THAT A BILLION
DOLLARS OF ONGOING FOR LOCAL
GOVERNMENTS FOR FLEXIBLE
SPENDING TO HELP THEM ATTACK.
THE PROBLEM OF HOMELESSNESS IN
THEIR COMMUNITY. THERE'S TWO
BILLION DOLLARS FOR AFFORDABLE
HOUSING BECAUSE FAR TOO FEW
PEOPLE. CAN AFFORD TO PURCHASE
A HOME OR EVEN RENT A HOME IN
THIS PARTICULAR STATE. IN TERMS
OF HEALTHCARE WE THOUGHT HOW
IMPORTANT IT WAS. TO HAVE
HEALTHCARE. OVER THE LAST.
THIRTEEN TO FIFTEEN MONTHS.
DURING A PANDEMIC WE SAW THE
FISSURES IN THE CRACKS WITHIN
OUR PUBLIC HEALTH
INFRASTRUCTURE. SO WE WANT TO
EXPAND MEDICARE ALL TO EVERYONE
IN THE STATE FIFTY EIGHT OVER
REGARDLESS OF IMMIGRATION
STATUS. WE WANT TO REMOVE THIS
AWFUL MEDICARE ACID TEST THAT
MAKES IT MAKES IT IMPOSSIBLE IF
YOU OWN ANYTHING TO BE A MEDIC
CAL. WE WANT TO INVEST IN OUR
YOUTH AND THEIR BEHAVIORAL
HEALTH A FOUR BILLION DOLLAR
INVESTMENT THE YOUTH BEHAVIORAL
HEALTH. IT ALSO TO WORK COUNTY
PARTNERS WE ARE HERE TO BE WITH
YOU TWO HUNDRED MILLION DOLLAR
ONGOING INVESTMENT FOR PUBLIC
COUNTY. HEALTH INFRASTRUCTURE.
IN EDUCATION IT'S A RECORD
AMOUNT OF FUNDING TWENTY ONE
THOUSAND DOLLARS PER PUPIL THE
HIGHEST AMOUNT IN THE STATE'S
HISTORY. FOR STUDENTS
STRUGGLING OR HOPING TO GET
INTO UC AND CSU WERE INCREASING
AEROBIC CAPACITY BY FIFTEEN
THOUSAND STUDENTS FOR FIFTEEN
THOUSAND MORE CALIFORNIA
STUDENTS ARE GOING TO BE ABLE
TO ATTEND THE UNIVERSITY
CALIFORNIA AND TO CALIFORNIA
STATE UNIVERSITY BECAUSE- OF
THIS BUDGET. ONLY 25% OF THE
STUDENTS IN THE STATE TO ATTEND
TO CARE THAT IS CHANGING WE ARE
NOW FACING IN A FULL TWO K.
1100% OF ALL FOUR YEAR OLD WILL
BE ABLE TO. BE ABLE TO ATTEND
T. K. BY THE TIME. THIS BUDGET
HAS BEEN FULLY IMPLEMENTED. AND
LASTLY IN EDUCATION. FAMILIES
CAN'T GO BACK TO WORK IF
THERE'S NO CHILD CARE SO WE'RE
ADDING ADDITIONAL TWO HUNDRED
THOUSAND MORE SLOTS FOR CHILD
CARE PLUS. FOR ALL THE CHILD
CARE. FOR ALL THE CHILD CARE
CENTERS WHO HAD SUCH A HARD
TIME THIS LAST YEAR WE HEAR
YOUR PAIN WE'RE INCREASING THE
RATES OF REIMBURSEMENT TO
REALLY HELPFUL CENTERS GET BACK
ON THEIR FEET. IN TERMS OF HOLE
HUMAN SERVICES WE HEARD. THAT
NOT EVERY CALIFORNIAN. I WAS
DOING OKAY BEFORE THIS PANDEMIC
SO MANY WERE ALREADY STRUGGLING.
WE'RE DOING THE RESTORATION OF
SIX HUNDRED MILLION TO SS I SS
P. WE ARE FINALLY. FINALLY
GOING TO IMPLEMENT OUR
DEVELOPMENTAL SERVICES RATE
STUDY AND THIS IS A BIG FIRST
STEP OVER EIGHT HUNDRED MILLION
DOLLARS THIS YEAR WITH THE GOAL
TO GET OVER THAT RATE STUDY
THRESHOLD. IN THE NEXT THREE
YEARS. FOR ALL OF US WHO RELY
ON IN HOME SUPPORT SERVICES TO
CARE FOR OUR LOVED ONES AND OUR
FAMILIES BUT THEY DON'T HAVE TO
GO TO A NURSING HOME WE'RE
DEFINITELY RESTORING THAT 7%
CUT. THAT WE TALKED ABOUT A
COUPLE YEARS AGO. IN TERMS OF
CRIMINAL JUSTICE AT THE SYSTEM
THAT IS BROKEN. IT DOESN'T DO
ITS PART IN TERMS OF ENSURING
THAT PEOPLE WHO GO IN COME OUT
BETTER SO WE'RE INVESTING IN
REHABILITATION OVER TWO HUNDRED
MILLION DOLLARS. WE'RE INSURING.
THAT LOW INCOME FAMILIES ALSO
GET THE ASSISTANCE THEY NEED
THEY'RE SADDLED WITH DEBT WITH
MANY OF THESE FEES WITH MANY OF
THESE PENALTIES SO WE ARE
WORKING TO REMOVE MANY OF THE
PENALTIES THAT THEY ARE FACING.
WAVING HUNDREDS OF BILLIONS OF
DOLLARS OF PENALTIES SO THEY
CAN GET THOSE SHACKLES REMOVED.
FROM THEIR BODIES. TWO HUNDRED
MILLION DOLLARS TO REDUCE GUN
VIOLENCE FOR THOSE CRITICAL
COMMUNITY ORGANIZATIONS. THAT
REALLY HAVE BEEN ON THE
FOREFRONT OF REDUCING GUN
VIOLENCE HERE IN OUR STATE. AND
LASTLY OUR COURT SYSTEM IS AN
EQUAL PARTNER IN OUR BRANCH OF
GOVERNMENT WERE MAKING AN OVER
FOUR HUNDRED MILLION DOLLAR
INVESTMENT OR REINVESTMENT. IN
OUR COURT SYSTEM AFTER SUCH A
VERY VERY DIFFICULT YEARS.
LASTLY WE HAVE A NUMBER HUGE
INVESTMENTS. BILLION DOLLARS
FOR WILDFIRES THREE POINT SEVEN
BILLION DOLLARS FOR DROUGHT WE
KNOW THAT THIS IS ONE OF THE
DRIEST YEARS IN OUR STATE'S
HISTORY THREE POINT SEVEN
BILLION DOLLARS IN CLIMATE WE
KNOW THAT IF WE DON'T MANAGE
CLIMATE CHANGE TO REVERSE THE
EFFECTS OF CLIMATE CHANGE WE'RE
GOING TO BE FIGHTING FIRES FOR
YEARS. SEVEN BILLION DOLLARS
FOR BROADBAND BILLION DOLLARS
BECAUSE FOR ECT K. TWELVE
FACILITIES BECAUSE IF WE DON'T
BUILD THE CLASSROOMS WE CAN'T
GET TICKETS EXPANDED AND WE
CAN'T EXPAND PRESCHOOL AND
LASTLY FOUR BILLION DOLLARS FOR
HIGHER EDUCATION FOR HOUSING AS
WELL AS EXPANSION BECAUSE WITH
SO MANY STUDENTS. GOING TO
ATTEND COLLEGE WE DID MAKE SURE
THERE'S ROOM FOR THEM THE PLA
PLACE FOR THEM. TO LIVE. LET ME
JUST WRAP UP I JUST THANKING.
EVERYBODY WHO HELPED PUT THIS
BUDGET TOGETHER. THIS IS
DEFINITELY A LEGISLATIVE TEAM
EFFORT. EVERYBODY ON THIS FLOOR
EVERY MEMBER OF PARTICIPATING
HEARINGS ALL THE STAFF. HAVE
HAD A HUGE ROLE IN PUTTING
TOGETHER THIS HISTORIC BUDGET
LET ME JUST THINK FIRST. OUR
VICE CHAIR MISTER FALL. REALLY
APPRECIATE ALL OF HIS. ALL OF
HIS GUIDANCE AND ALL OF HIS
COOPERATION OVER THE LAST YEAR.
ME JUST THANK OUR FIVE TEACHER
ARE FAR SOLDIERS. DR ARAMBULA
CARTY MISTER BLOOM. MISS
CARILLO AND MISS GARCIA FOR
THEIR INCREDIBLE WORK OVER THE
LAST FEW MONTHS. LET ME THINK.
THIS THE TEAM OUR STAFF JESUS
IS THE IN THE SPEAKER'S OFFICE
CHRISTIAN GRIFFITH OUR CHIEF
CONSULTANT OUR TIRE ASSEMBLY
BUDGET STAFF AS WELL AS MY
PERSONAL STUFF YOU PUT IN SO
MANY HOURS. INTO THIS BUDGET.
ME ALSO THANK OCHEN STOCK IN
THE REPUBLICAN FISCAL TEAM FOR
ALL THE TIME THAT THEY'VE
INVESTED IN MAKING SURE THAT
THIS BUDGETIS AS GOOD AS COULD
BE. I ALSO WANT TO THANK
SENATOR SKINNER WHO JUST GOT
DONE PRESENTING OUR BUDGET AS
WELL AS HER ENTIRE SENATE
BUDGET STOP. ALL I'M GONNA
THINK OUR INCREDIBLE FINANCE
TEAM DOWNSTAIRS FOR ALL THE
INCREDIBLE WORK THEY DO. ARE WE
ARE STILL HAVING ONGOING
DISCUSSIONS TO MAKE SURE THAT
WE CAN COME TO AN AGREEMENT.
FOR WORK I JUSTWANT TO THANK
THEM FOR THE HOURS THAT THEY
PUT INTO THIS BUDGET. BUT ALSO
THE HOURS THEY PUT INTO EACH OF
THE EARLY TRAILER BILLS EARLY
THIS YEAR'S AROUND SCHOOLS.
RUMBLE THE STATE'S STIMULUS
AROUND WILDFIRES. AND LET ME
JUST THANK THE BACKBONE OF OUR-
ASSEMBLY AS WELL WHETHER DOUBTS
ARE LDC ARE SIMPLY TV OR LARGE
COUNCIL OR SERGEANTS. AND NOW A
NEW. ADDED PART OF OUR FAMILY
OUR EIGHTEEN T. OPERATORS THIS
YEAR WOULD BE THE SAME WITHOUT
THE EIGHTEEN T. OPERATORS. ARM
MEMBERS THIS IS A BUDGET THAT I
BELIEVE WE WILL LOOK BACK OUT
VERY PROUDLY. IT'S A HUGE
OPPORTUNITY TO INVEST OUR STATE
NOT JST NEXT YEAR BUT REALLY.
FOR THE NEXT FIFTY YEARS. IS
LAYS THE FOUNDATION TOWARDS
EDUCATION TO HELP THOSE THAT
NEED THE HELP THE MOST. IT
INSURERS THAT FAMILIES ARE
GETTING OFF TO A STRONG START
AND THEY HAVE EVERY OPPORTUNITY
TO SUCCEED IN THE STATE. WITH
THAT I RESPECTFULLY ASK VOTE
ASK FOR YOUR AYE VOTE ON A. B.
ONE TWENTY EIGHT ARE BUDGET
BILL. THANK YOU RICH TANK MR
FONG YOU ARE RECOGNIZED. I
THANK YOU MISTER SPEAKER. A
MEMBERS THE COVERT NINETEEN
PANDEMIC. IT'S AN FAMILIES HAVE
STRUGGLED AND PERSEVERED OUR
SMALL BUSINESSES HAVE FOUGHT TO
SURVIVE WITH CONTINUOUS
UNCERTAINTY OUR COMMUNITIES
HAVE ENDURED CHALLENGE AFTER
CHALLENGE HOW WE CRAFT THE
STATE BUDGET HAS TREMENDOUS
IMPLICATIONS THERE ARE
PROPOSALS IN THIS BUDGET THAT
ARE NECESSARY AND HAVE MERIT.
INVESTMENTS IN PUBLIC HEALTH
BROADBAND ELIMINATING DEBT
INCURRED BY OUR SCHOOL
DISTRICTS SUPPORT FOR THE
DEVELOPMENTALLY DISABLED
COMMUNITY AND EMERGENCY FUNDING
FOR SPECIAL DISTRICTS
THROUGHOUT OUR STATE. CERTAINLY
THE BUDGET JEFF IN THE BAY AREA
AND I OUR EGGS EXPERIENCING A
BUDGET CYCLE UNLIKE ANY OTHER
WE'VE SEEN IN OUR STATE'S
HISTORY. AND I APPRECIATE THE
CIRCUMSTANCES AND PRESSURES
THAT HE HAS HAD TO NAVIGATE AND
TO NAVIGATE. THE COLLEAGUES I
HAVE SERIOUS RESERVATIONS TO AB
ONE TWENTY EIGHT. TOO OFTEN. WE
FALL INTO THE COMMON MENTALITY.
TO EVALUATE PROGRAMS BASED ON
THE AMOUNT WE SPEND. INSTEAD OF
RESULTS OF WHAT WE ARE TRYING
TO ACHIEVE. THIS BILL
ADMITTEDLY STILL LACKS
IMPORTANT DETAILS. DETAILS THAT
WILL DETERMINE WHETHER PROGRAMS
WILL ACTUALLY WORK OR NOT. MANY
WILL TOUT THE SIZE OF THIS
BUDGET. OVERLOOKING THE NEED
FOR A VITAL STRUCTURAL REFORMS
TO CRITICAL PROGRAMS THAT ARE
CURRENTLY IN EFFECTIVE. POURING
LARGE AMOUNTS OF MONEY INTO
PROGRAMS THAT ARE FUNDAMENTALLY
FLAWED OR MISMANAGED IS A
RECIPE FOR DISASTER. CREATING
MORE PROGRAMS AND EXPANDING
ONGOING SERVICES WITH A ONE
TIME DOLLARS. IS NOT SENSIBLE
AND I THINK MANY WOULD AGREE
THIS IS NOT RECOMMENDED.
CALIFORNIANS EXPECT US TO FIX
THE MANY BROKEN SYSTEMS IN OUR
STATE GOVERNMENT TO FOCUS
RESPONSIBLY ON THE CONTINUOUS
DANGERS OF CASH EVERY WILDFIRES
AND NOW WORSENING DROUGHT AN
OUTDATED ENERGY GRID AND TO
HAVE A REAL AND THOUGHTFUL
DEBATE ON PERMANENT TAX RELIEF
FOR CALIFORNIANS TRYING TO
FIGURE OUT. HOW TO LIVE AND
WORK IN OUR STATE WAY MEDIUM
HOME COST OVER SEVEN HUNDRED
THOUSAND DOLLARS. IN FACT WELL
I AND MANY OPPOSED TO TAX
INCREASES IN DEFERRALS OF
IMPORTANT TAX CREDITS MADE LAST
YEAR. IT WOULD BE REASONABLE TO
LOOK AT I'M DOING THOSE ACTIONS
NOW THAT WE HAVE A DIFFERENT
BUDGET OUTLOOK BUT THOSE TAX
INCREASES UNFORTUNATELY REMAIN.
IT GOES WITHOUT SAYING THAT OUR
STATE'S UNEMPLOYMENT SYSTEM IS
FUNDAMENTALLY BROKEN. THE EDT
SYSTEM CANNOT FUNCTION WITH ANY
SEMBLANCE OF COMPETENCE IN
CALIFORNIA HAS INCURRED A DEBT
OF TWENTY FOUR BILLION DOLLARS
IN THE UNEMPLOYMENT INSURANCE
FUND. A DEBT THAT IF IT IS NOT
ADDRESSED IN A SIGNIFICANT AND
SUBSTANTIAL WAY WILL LEAD TO
HIGHER TAXES PAID FOR AND BY
ARE ALREADY STRUGGLING SMALL
BUSINESSES. LESTAT WAS INCURRED
BECAUSE OF THE MISMANAGEMENT OF
STATE GOVERNMENT NOT BY OUR
LOCAL SMALL BUSINESSES. THE
LACK OF ACTION WILL ONLY LEAD
TO A LARGER TAX BURDEN THAT
HARD WORKING CALIFORNIANS WILL
HAVE TO BEAR IN THE FUTURE.
THIS IS UNDENIABLE. CALIFORNIA
IS FACING A SEVERE DROUGHT IN
OUR WATER SUPPLY IS QUICKLY
DWINDLING. FOLSOM LAKE FOR
EXAMPLE HASN'T SEEN WATER
LEVELS THIS LOW SINCE NINETEEN
SEVENTY SEVEN. THE STATE WATER
INFRASTRUCTURE IS CRUMBLING AS
WE ENTER ANOTHER DROUGHT AND
FIRE SEASON. THIS BUDGET STILL
DOES NOT PROVIDE ANY ASSURANCES
OF NEEDED WATER STORAGE. WE
HAVE SEEN THAT MORE SAVINGS IS
MORE PRUDENT THAN MORE SPENDING
BUT NEITHER THE GOVERNOR NOR
THIS LEGISLATIVE PROPOSAL SEEKS
TO REPLENISH THE MONEY
WITHDRAWN FROM THE STATE'S
SAVING A SAVINGS ACCOUNT
SOMETHING THAT WE MUST DO. THE
NONPARTISAN L. A. L. AS EVEN
TOLD US USING TOOLS DESIGNED
FOR A BUDGET CRISIS TO SUPPORT
STATE SPENDING AT THIS TIME IS
SHORT SIGHTED AND IT INVIOLABLE.
MEMBERS I WOULD ARGUE THAT
INSTEAD OF USING THE BUDGETS
FRAMEWORK THIS BUDGET FRAMEWORK
AS A SPENDING SPREE. WE NEED TO
EVALUATE THIS PROPOSAL AS WELL
AS FUTURE PROPOSALS AS A
MANAGEMENT PLAN. JUDGED BY
RESULTS AND ACCOUNTABILITY WE
HAVE SEEN THE VOLATILITY AND
UNCERTAINTY IN BUDGET
PROJECTIONS LOOKS CAN BE
DECEIVING THIS BUDGET IS LARGE
BUT THERE ARE SERIOUS CONCERNS
THAT THIS BUDGET IS
UNSUSTAINABLE WE NEED TO FOCUS
ON THE BASICS AND DEMAND
RESULTS BEFORE WE POUR BILLIONS
OF DOLLARS. OF PRECIOUS TAX
DOLLARS INTO MORE NEW PROGRAMS
AND A BROKEN SYSTEMS WITH NO
STRUCTURAL REFORMS AND FOR THAT
REASON I CANNOT SUPPORT THE
PATH THAT THIS BUDGET LEADS OUR
STATE DOWN. URGENT ABOUT. THANK
YOU MR FONG MISS CLARK SILVA.
YOU ARE RECOGNIZED. THANK YOU
MR SPEAKER AND MEMBERS MEMBERS
TODAY I RISE AND ASK US TO
REFLECT BACK JUST A YEAR AGO. A
YEAR AGO WHEN OUR STATE WAS
SHUT DOWN WHEN WE WERE LOSING
THOUSANDS OF JOBS. AND
THOUSANDS OF PEOPLE WERE DYING
ACROSS OUR COUNTRY. AND TO
THINK THAT JUST TOMORROW WE ARE
GOING TO BE RE OPENING. THAT WE
ARE SEEING NOT ONLY RE OPENING
RESILIENCY RECOVERING
REBOUNDING AND WE ARE ROARING
BACK. I WANT TO SPEAK TO TWO
PARTS OF THIS BUDGET THAT MEANS
SO MUCH TO ME SOME OF YOU HAVE
HEARD MAYBE THE BROKEN RECORD
ABOUT HOMELESSNESS. BECAUSE
THAT IS THE ONE AREA THAT WE
AGREE AS REPUBLICANS AND
DEMOCRATS THAT WE NEED TO DO
MORE IN THIS BUDGET IS DOING
EXACTLY THAT WE ARE PROVIDING
ONE BILLION DOLLARS OF ONGOING
AND FLEXIBLE FUNDING TO AID
LOCAL GOVERNMENTS TO COMBAT
HOMELESSNESS. WE'RE PROVIDING
ONE POINT TWO BILLION DOLLARS
FOR PROJECT HOME KEY FOR THOSE
CITIES THAT CHOOSE TO USE
MOTELS OR HOTELS FOR
HOMELESSNESS AND IN MY OWN
COUNTY STANTON DECIDED TO DO
THAT AND THEY'RE ALREADY
BUILDING TO HOUSE THOSE PEOPLE
WHO ARE READY. FOR THEIR OWN
PLACE TO LIVE. IN ADDITION
THERE IS A ONE POINT SEVEN FIVE
BILLION TO ALLEVIATE THE
BACKLOG IN AFFORDABLE HOUSING
CONSTRUCTION. AND MUCH MORE WE
KNOW THAT DOLLARS ARE NOT THE
ONLY WAY TO SOLVE HOMELESSNESS
IT TAKES LOCAL JURISDICTIONS IT
TAKES THE COUNTY THE FEDERAL
GOVERNMENT AND US NEIGHBORS
PEOPLE IN OUR COMMUNITY SAYING
YES. SAYING THAT IT IS NOT
ENOUGH TO SEND DOLLARS BUT WE
HAVE TO WORK TOGETHER TO NOT
ALLOW PEOPLE TO SLEEP ON OUR
CORNERS IN STREETS IT'S THAT
SIMPLE WORKING TOGETHER.
ANOTHER PART OF THE BUDGET IT'S
VERY EXCITING TO ME IS MONEY
THAT'S GOING TO BE PUT TOWARDS
CALIFORNIA ARTS NOW THE SEEM TO
BE VERY DIFFERENT TOPICS ARTS
AND HOMELESSNESS. AND YET WE
KNOW THAT CALIFORNIA IS ONE OF
THE MOST CREATIVE ECONOMIES OUT
THERE NOT ONLY OUR THEATERS OUR
MUSIC OUR MOTION PICTURES BUT
ALSO THE ARTIST THE ARTIST THAT
I BROUGHT TO LIFE OUR
COMMUNITIES. JUST THIS WEEK IN
IN THE HEIGHTS WAS RELEASED AND
THIS PICTURE MUSICAL MOVIE. IS
A TRIBUTE TO BEAUTIFUL FAMILIES
THAT HAVE IMMIGRATED TO OUR
GREAT USA SO I'M EXCITED TO SEE
ONE HUNDRED MILLION DOLLARS
GOING TOWARDS THE CALIFORNIA
OUT ARTS COUNCIL GRANTS THAT
CAN BE USED ACROSS OUR STATE
FOR ALL OF THOSE CREATIVE
INDIVIDUALS AND THEIR- THEIR
ORGANIZATIONS IN ADDITION FIFTY
MILLION DOLLARS. FOR THE ARTS
COUNCIL IN CONJUNCTION WITH THE
LABOR AND WORKFORCE DEVELOPMENT
AGAIN TO SUPPORT THOSE JOBS
THAT HAVE BEEN LOST THAT WE
KNOW. BRING THAT VIBRANT COLOR
TO OUR COMMUNITY SO I RISE IN
SUPPORT AND ASK YOU TO SUPPORT.
AB ONE TWENTY EIGHT. THANK YOU
MISS SILVA DOT RANDY. YOU ARE
RECOGNIZED. THANK YOU MR
SPEAKER AND MEMBERS THIS BUDGET
DOES NOT RETURN OUR STATE BACK
TO NORMAL RATHER IT'S BOLDNESS
LEADS US TO A STRONGER AND
BETTER CALIFORNIA FOR ALL. THE
CALIFORNIA THAT LEAVES NO ONE
BEHIND BY INVESTING IN EVERY
CALIFORNIA ESPECIALLY OUR MOST
VULNERABLE. UNDERSTANDING THAT
THE PANDEMIC DID NOT HIT US ALL
EQUALLY OUR LEADERS AND SURE IN
THIS BUDGET THAT SMART
INVESTMENTS TODAY. CONTINUE TO
LEAD US TOWARDS EQUITY. AS THE
CHAIR OF THE BUDGET SUB
COMMITTEE NUMBER ONE ON HEALTH
AND HUMAN SERVICES I AM
GRATEFUL THAT THIS BUDGET
DIRECTS THE BOUNTIFUL RESOURCE
IN IT. TOWARDS THOSE THAT NEED
THEM THE MOST WE MAKE MAJOR
INVESTMENTS IN OUR SOCIAL
SERVICE PROGRAMS AND MOST OF
WHAT YOU SEE IN THIS OUR PLANS
AND PRIORITIES THAT CHAMPIONS
AND ADVOCATES HAVE BEEN WORKING
ON FOR YEARS. THESE INVESTMENTS
ENSURE THAT ALL OF OUR
COMMUNITIES CAN MEET BASIC
NEEDS FEED THEMSELVES AND THEIR
CHILDREN AND BE CARED FOR AND
RECEIVE SUPPORT WHEN THEY FACE
TRAUMA INTERGENERATIONAL
POVERTY UNEMPLOYMENT DISEASE OR
DISABILITY. I AM PROUD TO
ANNOUNCE THAT THIS BUDGET
BEFORE US TODAY PROVIDE
STABILITY FOR THOSE WITH
INTELLECTUAL AND DEVELOPMENTAL
DISABILITIES WHO SYSTEM HAS
BEEN ROCKED BY KOBE AND HAS
BEEN HISTORICALLY UNDER FUNDED.
BY FUNDING THE DDS RATE STUDY
WE WILL FULFILL THE PROMISE OF
THE LAND SHERMAN ACT ON WHICH
SO MANY RELY TO LIVE A FULL
SAFE AND DIGNIFIED LIFE IN OUR
COMMUNITY. WE MAKE CRITICAL
CHANGES TO MODERNIZE THE CAL
WORKS PROGRAM SO THAT IT CAN
PROVIDE REAL TRAUMA INFORMED
SUPPORT TO PARENTS AND THEIR
CHILDREN IN THE SAFETY NET
PROGRAM. THIS POWERFUL PROGRAM
CAN BREAK THE CYCLE OF POVERTY
SO THAT THESE PARENTS AND
CHILDREN HAVE AN OPPORTUNITY.
TO LIVE THE CALIFORNIA DREAM.
YEAH OF LIVING IN THE BREAD
BASKET OF THE WORLD IS THOSE
WHO WORKED SO DILIGENTLY TO PUT
FOOD ON OUR TABLES. TOO OFTEN
FACE FOOD INSECURITY
THEMSELVES. THE SOLUTION TO
FIGHTING HUNGER AT RECORD
LEVELS IN CALIFORNIA IS TO
PROVIDE STRONG INVESTMENTS IN
OUR EMERGENCY FOOD
INFRASTRUCTURE. THIS BUDGET
PROVIDES SIGNIFICANT
INVESTMENTS TO SUPPORT FOOD FOR
ALL AND ALSO TO FUND ARE
INDISPENSABLE FOOD BANKS AND
PROVIDE DISASTER RESILIENCY IN
THE FUTURE. WE PROVIDE A
SUBSTANTIAL GRANT INCREASE TO
SS I SS P. RECIPIENTS AND WE
FOUND A MULTITUDE OF SUPPORTS
IN OUR CHILD WELFARE AND FOSTER
CARE SYSTEM. OTHER NOTABLE
INVESTMENTS IN OUR HUMAN
SERVICES PROGRAM INCLUDE
EXPANDING THE ADULT PROTECTIVE
SERVICES. INCREASING CAPACITY
IN INFRASTRUCTURE AND OUR
SENIOR NUTRITION PROGRAMS
BROADENING LAND FROM AN EARLY
START TWO THREE AND FIVE YEAR
OLDS AND SUPPORTING THE
CALIFORNIA REDUCING DISPARITIES
PROJECT. I WANT TO ACKNOWLEDGE
THE EXTRA ORDINARY WORK DONE BY
THE ADMINISTRATION TO ADDRESS
THE USE BEHAVIORAL HEALTH.
EARLY IN THE PANDEMIC MANY OF
US RECOGNIZE THE LIKELIHOOD
THAT A BEHAVIORAL HEALTH CRISIS
WOULD BE THE TSUNAMI THAT
RESULTS FROM PROVIDES
EARTHQUAKE. TRAGICALLY DATA
BEARS OUT. BEARS THAT OUT SHE
SICK. RISING RATES OF MENTAL
ILLNESS AND SUBSTANCE ABUSE
ESPECIALLY AMONG OUR CHILDREN.
IT IS LONG BEEN UNDERSTOOD THAT
SOCIAL DETERMINANTS OF HEALTH
HEALTH INEQUITIES AND UNDER
FUNDED PUBLIC HEALTH
INFRASTRUCTURE ARE KEY FACTORS
AFFECTING THE HEALTH OF ALL
CALIFORNIANS. WE PROVIDE A TWO
HUNDRED MILLION DOLLAR
AUGMENTATION TO LOCAL HEALTH
JURISDICTIONS TO MEET THE CORE
PUBLIC HEALTH INFRASTRUCTURE
NEEDS. AN INVESTMENT THAT ISN'T
ACCOMPANIED BY RESOURCES TO
FUND AN ANALYSIS OF LOCAL
PUBLIC HEALTH STAFFING AND
OTHER NEEDS IN ORDER TO INFORM
FUTURE FUNDING DECISIONS. WE
MUST ESTABLISH A ROBUST AND
EQUITABLE SYSTEM THAT WORKS FOR
ALL. THE CALIFORNIA ADVANCING
AND INNOVATING MEDIKAL CAL AIM
PROPOSAL WILL DO THAT BY
STREAMLINING TRANSFORMING AND
FOUNDATIONAL CHANGING MEDICAL
DELIVERY SERVICE AND FINANCING.
I LOOK FORWARD TO CONTINUING
CONVERSATIONS AND APPRECIATE.
THE ONGOING DISCUSSIONS TAKING
PLACE. THE PANDEMIC HAS FURTHER
EXACERBATED RACIAL AND ETHNIC
HEALTH DISPARITIES AND MADE IT
CLEAR THAT ACCESS TO
COMPREHENSIVE HEALTH CARE IS
NECESSARY FOR EVERY RESIDENT IN
OUR STATE. I AM THRILLED THAT
THIS BUDGET FURTHER OF ROADS
THE IMMORAL EXCLUSION OF MANY
TAXPAYERS AND THEIR FAMILIES
FOR MEDICAL COVERAGE BY
EXPANDING FULL SCOPE MEDICAL.
TO ALL INCOME ELIGIBLE
IMMIGRANTS OVER THE AGE OF
FIFTY. THE HEALTH AND HUMAN
SERVICES INVESTMENTS IN OUR
PLAN REFLECT NOT ONLY THE CARE
THE SUPPORT AND SERVICES THAT
PEOPLE NEED TODAY. BUT THE
CALIFORNIA THAT WE WANT FOR ALL
OF OUR CHILDREN AND FAMILIES IN
A POST PANDEMIC FUTURE THAT IS
BEAMING WITH OPPORTUNITY FOR
ALL FUELED BY EQUITY. I WANT TO
THANK THE GOVERNOR THE
ADMINISTRATION THE DEPARTMENT
OF FINANCE THE LEGISLATIVE
ANALYST'S OFFICE. THE COUNTIES
THE ADVOCATES ON THE PUBLIC
THANK YOU MEMBERS AND I
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR AN AYE
VOTE. THANK YOU DR ARAMBULA
MEMBERS IF YOU'D LIKE TO
PURCHASE. IN PLEASE RAISE YOUR
MICROPHONE. AT THIS TIME. MISS
REAVIS YOU ARE RECOGNIZED THANK
YOU MISTER SPEAKER MEMBERS I'D
STAND TODAY TO SPEAK ABOUT THE
INVESTMENTS BEING MADE IN THIS
BUDGET BILL TO ADDRESS
HOMELESSNESS FIRST I HAVE TO
THANK OUR BUDGET CHAIR ARE
BUDGET SUB FOR CHAIR AND OF
COURSE OUR SPEAKER FOR RISING
UP TO MEET THIS MOMENT WE'VE
HEARD FROM THIS ADMINISTRATION
THAT THERE IS A DESIRE TO
COMBAT HOMELESSNESS WELL THIS
BUDGET PROVIDES AN OPPORTUNITY
FOR US TO PUT OUR MONEY WHERE
OUR MOUTH IS. AS MANY OF YOU
KNOW SEVERAL OF US IN THIS
HOUSE HAVE WORKED ON
HOMELESSNESS INCLUDING MY
SEATMATE FROM FULLER TEN AND
MYSELF FOR THE LAST SEVERAL
YEARS BOB THIS YEAR I HAD A
BILL THAT WOULD HAVE GENERATED
ON GOING FUNDING FOR
HOMELESSNESS FOR THE FIRST TIME
EVER BUT BECAUSE OF THE WORK IN
THIS BUDGET- I'M RISING TODAY
TO SAY I ENCOURAGE YOU TO
SUPPORT THIS MEASURE.
HOMELESSNESS ISN'T AN URBAN OR
RURAL ISSUE IT'S A CALIFORNIA
ISSUE OUR CONSTITUENTS WANT TO
KNOW THAT THIS ISSUE IS BEING
TAKEN SERIOUSLY AND FOR SEVERAL
YEARS THIS LEGISLATURE HAS
SHOWN THAT IT'S WILLING TO DO
WHAT IS NEEDED TO MOVE
CALIFORNIA FORWARD IN REDUCING
OUR HOMELESS POPULATION. I HOPE
THAT THE ADMINISTRATION WILL
SUPPORT THESE INVESTMENTS AND
THE ADDITIONAL ACCOUNTABILITY
MEASURES THAT WILL BE FOLLOWING
SHORTLY IN OUR TRAILER BILLS
THANK YOU AND I URGE YOU TO
SUPPORT AB ONE TWENTY EIGHT.
THANK MYSTERY OF US. DR CHOI.
YOU RECORD. THANK YOU MISTER
SPEAKER AND MEMBERS- TODAY I
RISE TO IN OPPOSITION TO
ASSEMBLY BID A LOT ONE TWENTY
EIGHT THE BUDGET BILL OUGHT
BEFORE US ARE TODAY TO NO MORE
THAN OUR TWO HUNDRED SPACES
HAVE BILLION. ACCORDING TO THE
PROVIDE SO ON A FEW AREAS ARE-
THE I ALSO PULL THOUGH SO IT'S
AS SO OUR SYSTEM- FOR VETERAN
SO. AND- ON- SOME THE HEALTH.
WON'T WORK FOR- HOWEVER I AM
DEEPLY- THE DOT THAT THE BUDGET
BILL NOT THE ALL WERE SO MANY
THE FROM FUNDING FOR X. LOAN
TIME. THIS INCLUDE A THREE
POINT. BILLION A GROWING FIVE
BILLION DOLLAR ANNUALLY TO A
SOME ACT. SO ALZADO LOCAL BASIS.
NINE BASED OFF SCHOOL ARE ARE
GROUP. AND THE- BUT THE NEW THE
FUNDING LIMIT FUNDING TO SPEED
STUDENTS INC SO. I WAS SO FOR
MORE OPPORTUNITIES SO FOR
PARENTS AND STUDENTS WHO DESIRE
HEIAU. HI ARE ALL QUALITY OF
EDUCATION WITH THE LOSS
LIMITATION ZAPATO SHOULD BE
SUPPORTED OR NOT EQUAL FUNDING
BASIS- THE BUDGET ALSO ALL
PROMISE OF FOUR BILLION DOLLARS
SO OF A FUTURE PROP NINETY
EIGHT THE GENERAL GROWTH. BUT
THE WHEN YOU LOOK AT THE
LANGUAGE IN THE TRAILER BILLS
IT IS EXPECTED TO LIMIT THE
RESOURCES SO THE LOCAL
EDUCATION AGENCIES ARE BASED ON
ON ON UNDUPLICATED CHILDREN AND
ROMAN THOUGHT INGRESA. TU K.
THROUGH SIX. SO SCHOOLS. YOU
HAD AGAIN NOT WILL BE EXCLUDED
A FROM THE ADDITIONAL FUNDING
SOURCES SO FROM PROP NINETY
EIGHT. JANVIER UNFAIRNESS ALL
OF THIS BUDGET WAS SO TOTAL
SCORES. THIS BUDGET THE
CONTINUOUS THE GROWTH OF A
GOVERNMENTAL WIDER FAILING TO
ADDRESS OUR AUDIBLE CONTROLLER
COST OF LIVING TO PREPARE
OURSELVES FOR SUCCESS AS WE
MOVE OUT OF THIS SO CALLED IT
UP AND THEN MAKE A- AGAIN.
ALTHOUGH THERE ARE MANY SELECT
THE ELEMENTS ARE AND AS WE
HEARD THE IN THIS BUDGET THAT
THOUGHT I. OUR SUPPORT AND OUR-
GOOD THE DIRECTION THAT THOUGH-
WE ARE HEADING BUT THERE'S
GE NO VOTE ON THIS OF BUDGET-
SO HOLDER BEFORE US TODAY THANK
YOU. TECDAX CHOI IS WALDRON.
YOU ARE RECOGNIZED THANK YOU MR
SPEAKER AND MEMBERS I RISE IN
OPPOSITION TO AB ONE TWENTY
EIGHT WHILE THIS BUDGET
INCLUDES MANY VERY SUPPORTABLE
AND MANY MUCH NEEDED PROGRAMS-
AND FUNDING. IT ALSO
DRAMATICALLY EXPANDS THE SCOPE
OF GOVERNMENT WITH NEW PROGRAMS
THAT WILL NOT BE SUSTAINABLE IN
THE NEAR FUTURE. LAWMAKERS WILL
BE LOOKING TO EITHER CUT
PROGRAMS THAT JUST STARTED OR
RAISE TAXES NEITHER OF WHICH
WOULD BE GOOD GOVERNANCE
INSTEAD OF FIXING THE BROKEN
PARTS OF GOVERNMENT WE'RE
SIMPLY EXPANDING IT. WE ALL
KNOW THIS JUST LOOK AT THE WORK
BUT THIS FUNCTIONAL EDT IS
CAUSING OUR OFFICES. IT'S
EXHIBIT A OF HOW BROKEN
GOVERNMENT AGENCIES CAN BE.
LET'S GET BACK TO BASICS AND
FIX WHAT'S BROKEN BEFORE WE
SPEND MORE. THIS BUDGET ALSO
DOES NOT REVERSE NEARLY NINE
POINT TWO BILLION IN TAX
INCREASES IMPOSED LAST YEAR.
MAKING CALIFORNIA UNAFFORDABLE
TO SO MANY. WE SHOULD BE
FOCUSED ON PREPARING FOR
POSSIBLE ECONOMIC DOWNTURN. IF
IN THE FUTURE WE SHOULD PAY
BACK THE SEVEN POINT EIGHT
BILLION TAKEN FROM THE RAINY
DAY FUND IN ORDER TO MAKE OUR
STATE MORE RESILIENT I CANNOT
SUPPORT THIS BUDGET TODAY AND I
URGE A NO VOTE. MISTER CARE
YOUR RECORD. THANK YOU MR
SPEAKER AND MEMBERS I RISE
TODAY TO JUST DISCUSS TO SIMPLE
THINGS I THINK A YEAR AGO WE
HAD A COMMITTEE OF THE WHOLE IN
THE BUDGET WHEN WE WERE FACING
DIRE CUTS AND MANY OF THE
MEMBERS OF THE WOMEN'S CAUCUS
MYSELF INCLUDED STOOD UP AND
ASKED FOR US TO PASS A FEMINIST
BUDGET WE TALKED ABOUT WHAT IT
MEANT TO TAKE CARE OF
CALIFORNIA'S MOST VULNERABLE
PEOPLE OUR CHILDREN ARE
ELDERLY. THOSE LIVING WITH
DISABILITIES AND I THINK IT'S
MY COLLEAGUES WHO SAID THIS
BUDGET IS A LOT OF THOSE THINGS
AND IN INCREDIBLE WAYS IT MOVES
THE BALL FORWARD ON
TRANSITIONAL KINDERGARTEN FOR
ALL CHILDREN IT STEPS UP FOR
THOSE LIVING WITH DISABILITIES
IT FOCUSES ON SOLVING OUR
HOMELESSNESS CRISIS I THINK ALL
OF THAT IS INCREDIBLY
IMPORTANT. BUT THERE ARE TWO
THINGS THAT I URGE US TO PAY
ATTENTION TO MOVING FORWARD ONE
IS ACCOUNTABILITY TIME AND
AGAIN WE SEE FROM OUR
INCREDIBLE STATE AUDITOR THAT
OUR DOLLARS ARE GOING BACK TO
THE COUNTIES AND WE ARE GETTING
THE RESULTS THAT WE EXPECT INTO
IS WE CONTINUE TO FUND THESE
PROGRAMS WE MUST BE HOLDING
THOSE PEOPLE WHO GET THOSE
DOLLARS ACCOUNTABLE TO ENSURE
WE'RE SEEING. THINGS IMPROVE
FOR ALL CALIFORNIANS. SECONDLY
I HAVE TO AGREE WITH MY
COLLEAGUE. WHO SPOKE JUST
BEFORE ME ABOUT RESERVES. YOU
KNOW AS ONE OF THE MEMBERS
WHO'S BEEN HERE THE SHORTEST
TENURE AND MAYBE HERE. MANY
MORE YEARS THAN THOSE OF YOU
THAT TURNED OUT IN JUST A FEW
YEARS. I MAY BE HERE. WHEN THE
RECESSION HIT. WE MAY ALL BE
HERE WHEN A RECESSION HITS. AND
IT IS INCUMBENT UPON US TO
ENSURE THAT WE HAVE SAVED FOR
THAT RAINY DAY. AND ALTHOUGH I
COMMEND THIS BODY AND THE
SENATE FOR GOING FURTHER THAN
MANY THE ADMINISTRATION AND
THAT WE DO NOT GO FAR ENOUGH.
WE NEED TO ENSURE THAT WE ARE
REPLENISHING OUR RAINY DAY
FUND. THAT WE ARE PAYING BACK.
THE BORROWING WE DID LAST YEAR
WHEN WE HAD TO MAKE EXTENSIVE
CUTS. AND WE NEED TO BE FOR.
FOR PASSING A RESPONSIBLE
BUDGET THAT ENSURES THAT FUTURE
BODIES HAVE THOSE RAINY DAY
RESERVES WHEN THEY NEED IT
THANK YOU MEMBERS. THANK YOU
MISTER A HAVE. THIS
PETRIE-NORRIS YOU ARE
RECOGNIZED. THANK YOU MR
SPEAKER AND MEMBERS. I JUST
TWELVE MONTHS AGO WE STOOD HERE
ON THIS FLOOR CONFRONTING A
HISTORIC BUDGET DEFICIT. FAST
FORWARD TWELVE MONTHS AND TODAY
WE ARE IN A MUCH DIFFERENT
POSITION A REMARKABLY DIFFERENT
POSITION WE HAVE A HISTORIC
BUDGET SURPLUS. AND THIS
SURPLUS GIVES US AN INCREDIBLE
OPPORTUNITY TO FORGE A JAST
SWIFT AND ROBUST RECOVERY FOR
CALIFORNIA WE SHOULD BE
THINKING BOWL. WE SHOULD BE
THINKING BIG AND THERE ARE SO
MANY EXCITING PROGRAMS THAT ARE
PART OF THIS BUDGET. HOWEVER
WE'VE ALSO GOT TO MAKE SURE
THAT WE ARE GETTING THE
FUNDAMENTALS RIGHT THAT WE ARE
AS AS MY COLLEAGUE JUST SAID
SAVING FOR A RAINY DAY THAT WE
ARE INSURING BUDGET RESILIENCE
SO THAT WHEN THE INEVITABLE
WHEN THE INEVITABLE CYCLICAL
DOWNTURN TIMES WE DO NOT FIND
OURSELVES IN A POSITION OF
HAVING. TO CUT PROGRAMS AND CUT
SERVICES FOR THE CALIFORNIANS
WHO WE REPRESENT AND WHO WE WHO
WE FIGHT FOR EACH AND EVERY DAY
AND SO I WOULD ADD MY VOICE TO
THOSE. URGING URGING US TO GO
FURTHER STILL IN INCREASING OUR
RESERVES AND ENSURING THAT WE
ARE PAYING BACK THE FULL TWELVE
BILLION DOLLARS IN AD BUDGET
SOLUTIONS THAT SAYS THAT WE
IMPLEMENTED LAST YEAR I AM
GRATEFUL TO THE BUDGET CHAIR
AND BUDGET COMMITTEE THAT THIS
BUDGETS- PROPOSAL DOES GO
FURTHER THAN THE GOVERNOR'S
PROPOSAL- WOULD LIKE TO YOU ACT
CONTINUES CONVERSATION AS WE
MOVE THROUGH THE PROCESS OF.
RECENT BUDGET TRAILER BILLS AND
BUDGET BILL JUNIORS SO THAT WE
CAN ENSURE THAT WE'RE BUILDING
A STRONG FOUNDATION FOR
CALIFORNIA THAT WE'RE BUILDING
A STRONG FOUNDATION FOR THIS
RECOVERY AND THAT WE CAN BUILD
BACK CALIFORNIA. BETTER THAN
BEFORE THANK YOU. THANK YOU
WITH PIZZA NORRIS. MR MCCARTY
YOU ARE RECOGNIZED THANK YOU
MISTER SPEAKER I RISE IN STRONG
SUPPORT OF THIS
TRANSFORMATIONAL BUDGET
ESPECIALLY RELATE TO OUR
SCHOOLS AND OUR KIDS BUT BEFORE
THAT I JUST WANT TO TOUCH ON
THIS ISSUE WITH THE RESERVE.
AND OUR BUDGET CHAIR NOTED IT
BUT I'LL JUST HIGHLIGHTED AGAIN
WAS HOW THEY JUST BY A FEW
SPEAKERS BUT- MORE- MORE
DIRECTLY BY OUR VICE CHAIR OF
THE BUDGET FROM FRESNO
SENSUALLY SAYS THAT WE'RE BEING
IRRESPONSIBLE AND NOT SAVING
FOR THE RAINY DAY WHAT JUST
THAT'S A SPOT FALSE NOT TRUE
OUR RESERVE IN THIS BUDGET IS
NORTH OF TWENTY FIVE BILLION
DOLLARS WE RESTORE THE RESERVE
WHERE IT WAS. IT'S AT HISTORIC
HIGH I RESERVE IN THREE YEARS
WHICH FROM PLANNING FOR IT WILL
BE THIRTY FIVE BILLION DOLLARS
TEN MORE BILLION THAN HISTORIC
HIGH SO THIS BUDGET SHOWS. IS
THAT WE CAN WALK AND CHEW GUM
AT THE SAME TIME WE CAN FOCUS
ON BEING RESPONSIBLE BUT INVEST
IN THE FUTURE BECAUSE LET'S
FACE IT WE HAVE AN UNBELIEVABLE
GROWTH AND REVENUES FROM THE
WEALTHIEST CALIFORNIANS. AND SO
WHAT CAN WE DO WITH THAT INVEST
INVEST IN THE REST OF
CALIFORNIANS TO MAKE SURE WE
CAN ALL CATCH UP. AND WE HAVE
ONE TIME MONEY FROM THE FEDERAL
GOVERNMENT THAT WE ARE SPENDING
ON ONE TIME THINGS. AND AGAIN
THAT THE USE OF THE TERM
TRANSFORMATIONAL IS PROBABLY
SOMETIMES OVERSTATED BUT IN
THIS INSTANCE. I WILL SAY IT'S
NOT THIS BUDGET WILL CHANGE
LIVES IT WILL CHANGE THE
TRAJECTORY. FOR SO MANY KIDS IN
CALIFORNIA THIS CLEARLY IS THE
BEST BUDGET THAT I VOTED ON IN
SEVEN YEARS. THE BEST EDUCATION
BUDGET BUT THEY THIS MAY BE THE
BEST EDUCATION BUDGET IN ANY
YEAR. AND I GUARANTEE ALL OF
YOU WHEN YOU RAN FOR OFFICE
TALKED ABOUT ARE YOU OUR KIDS
OUR SCHOOLS. OUR COLLEGES
REGARDLESS OF YOUR POLITICAL
AFFILIATION WHEREVER YOU'RE
FROM. WELL THIS IS THIS IS THE
DAY TO CAST THE MOST
CONSEQUENTIAL VOTE. ON OUR KIDS
ON OUR P. THREE SIXTEEN SCHOOL
SYSTEM. THIS IS THE DAY FOR
CALIFORNIANS AND FUTURE
GENERATIONS. OTHER BUDGETARY
LAID IT OUT THIS IMPACTS THE
LIVES FOR MANY KIDS IN
CALIFORNIANS I'M GONNA FOCUS ON
THE NUMBERS. BUT WHAT THIS WILL
MEAN TO PEOPLE THE FAMILIES.
FOR OUR YOUNGEST LEARNERS FROM
EARLY EDUCATION THE AMOUNT OF
MONEY WE'RE PUTTING FORWARD. IS
UNFATHOMABLE TO BE LOOK AT
SOMETIMES NORTH OF FIVE BILLION
DOLLARS IN NEW MONEY. SO WHAT
THIS MEANS IF YOU'RE A FAMILY
ON A WAITING LIST. TRYING TO
GET CHILD CARE THE LIST WE CUT
IN HALF. FROM FOUR HUNDRED
THOUSAND TO TWO HUNDRED
THOUSAND BY US INCREASING.
ANOTHER TWO HUNDRED THOUSAND
CHILD CARE SLOTS. FOR RATES FOR
PROVIDERS WHO ARE BARELY
HANGING ON THE SO MAKE SURE
THAT YOUR PROGRAMS ARE
FINANCIALLY VIABLE. BUT MORE
IMPORTANTLY THIS ALLOW YOUR-
WORKERS TO NOT BE PAID POVERTY
WAGES SO THEY CAN STICK AROUND
AND FOCUS ON OUR YOUNGEST
LEARNERS AND NOT MOVE ON TO GO
WORK. AT SOME OTHER LOW WAGE
JOB BECAUSE WE SHOULD VALUE.
ARE WORKERS IN THIS FIELD.
WE'RE GOING TO ELIMINATE FAMILY
FEES TO MAKE SURE THAT FAMILIES
CAN REALLY AFFORD. THESE
PROGRAMS. AND WE ARE GOING TO
MAKE SURE WE HAD UNIVERSAL
TRANSITIONAL KINDERGARTEN ONCE
AND FOR ALL FOR ALL FOUR YEAR
OLDS TO MAKE SURE THE MIDDLE
CLASS FAMILIES. DON'T HAVE TO
PAY THE THOUSAND A TWO THOUSAND
DOLLARS A MONTH FOR PRE K. 25%
OF KIDS IN CALIFORNIA GETTY K.
OTHER THREE QUARTERS DON'T.
THAT'S FUNDAMENTALLY UNFAIR
WE'RE CHANGING THAT ONCE AND
FOR ALL. FOR OUR PUBLIC
SCHOOLS. THE PER PUPIL FUNDING
IN THIS BUDGET FOR OUR SCHOOLS.
IS OVER TWENTY ONE THOUSAND
DOLLARS PER STUDENT WHAT DOES
THAT MEAN THREE YEARS AGO WE
WERE AT TWELVE THOUSAND. SO
THIS MEANS THAT SCHOOLS CAN
BRING BACK IN RICHMOND PROGRAMS
PAY THEIR TEACHERS LIVING WAGES
AS WELL MAKE SURE THAT WE DON'T
CUT THE BASICS IN OUR
CLASSROOMS REDUCE CLASS SIZES
FOR TWO FOR OUR EARLIEST GRADES
WHICH THE BUFFET GOVERNOR
PROVIDES ITS WE EMBRACE. WE'RE
GOING TO DOUBLE THE AMOUNT OF
KIDS AND AFTER SCHOOL PROGRAMS
IF YOUR FAMILY WANTS TO HAVE A
PLACE FOR YOUR KID TO GO BACK
TO SCHOOL SAFE. WE'RE GONNA
DOUBLE THE AMOUNT OF SLOTS IN
AFTER SCHOOL PROGRAMS AND NOT
IT IS WELL IN THE NEXT FIVE
YEARS IS GOING TO BE
UNIVERSALLY ACCESSIBLE FOR ALL
KIDS AFTER SCHOOL. SO WE SHOULD
BE WAITING LESS FOR THOSE AS
WELL. FIRST OUR SCHOOL MEALS
PROGRAMS THAT ARE. OUR
COLLEAGUE FROM THAT SAN
FERNANDO VALLEY'S BEEN PUSHING
FOR YEARS WE'RE GONNA MAKE SURE
THAT'S UNIVERSALLY ACCESSIBLE
FOR SCHOOL MEALS SO KIDS DON'T
HAVE TO SCRAMBLED ON THEIR-
DOWN THEIR DEBT OWED AND BE
SEEN BY THEIR SCHOOL DEBT FEES.
FOR FOOD WE'RE GONNA MAKE SURE
THAT THAT SCHOOL MEALS ARE THE
NORM. FOR OUR COLLEGES
UNIVERSITIES FOR OUR FUTURE.
THIS IS REALLY IMPORTANT TO OUR
ECONOMY TO MAKE SURE WE HAVE
GRADUATES TO FILL THE JOBS OF
TODAY AND TOMORROW. WE'RE FULLY
FUNDING OUR COMMUNITY COLLEGES
GIVING THEM A SUPER CALL I'M-
PROMOTING PROGRAMS LIKE A
MOSHE. ARISING SCHOLARS
WEDNESDAY IN MESA TO HELP THE
NEXT GENERATION OF STUDENTS GET
INTER COMMUNICABLE TO HAVE A
PIPELINE TO SUCCESS. FOR HIGHER
EDUCATION. FOR CSU. OVER NINE
THOUSAND MORE FAMILIES WHO GET
A REJECTION NOTICE EVERY YEAR
BECAUSE ANA SLOTS IN THE CSU.
WILL HAVE A SPOT. FOR YOU SEE.
OVER SIX THOUSAND FOR OUR FOR
OUR COVETED COLLEGES AT
BERKELEY. SAN DIEGO UCLA. WITH
FOR THE LAST FEW YEARS. HAVE
HAD ROUGHLY ONE IN THREE SLOTS
FOR EVERY. FOR EVERY NON
RESIDENTS TE WORKING
CALIFORNIAN WE'RE GOING TO
LOWER THAT NUMBER AND ABOUT
FIVE THOUSAND ADDITIONAL HIGH
SCHOOL GRADUATES WILL BE ABLE
TO GO TO THE UNIVERSITY OF IT A
CALIFORNIA AND THOSE THREE
CAMPUSES PLUS OVERALL AND THE
OTHER SIX UC UNDERGRADUATE
CAMPUSES. BIRD FINANCIAL AID WE
LITERALLY HAVE A PLAN HERE TO
MAKE COLLEGE DEBT FREE IN
CALIFORNIA IF YOU LOOK AT
FAMILY'S FINANCIAL
CONTRIBUTIONS EXISTING
FINANCIAL AID WORKING FIFTEEN
HOURS A WEEK WE HAVE A PLAN
HERE IN A PATH TO MAKE COLLEGE
DEBT FREE FOR THOSE FAMILIES.
AS WELL AS MAKING CUT COMMUNITY
COLLEGE THE CAL GRANT PROGRAMS
WORK FOR THEM AND NOT EXCLUDE
THEM SO IT'S SON THIS IS A
BUDGET THAT WE ALL TALKED ABOUT
FOR DECADES. THE MAKING SURE
THAT WE CHANGE THE EDUCATION
SYSTEM SO IT'S NOT FOR THE FEW
BUT FOR THE MANY AND THIS IS
SOMETHING WE SHOULD ALL BE
PROUD WITH I'M CERTAINLY-
PLEASE WIRE LEADERSHIP SPEAKER-
LET US IN THIS IN THIS QUEST AS
WELL AS OUR BUDGET SHARE AND I
ASK FOR A STRONG I DON'T THINK
YOU. THANK YOU MEASURE
ACCORDING THANK YOU MEMBERS SEE
NO OTHER MEMBERS SEEKING
RECOGNITION. MISTER TANK YOU
MAY CLOSE. THANK YOU MISTER
SPEAKER. I HAVE THE HONOR WAS
SO MANY OTHERS IN THIS ROOM OF
BEING IN THE CLASS OF TWENTY
TWELVE. THEN I KNOW THE. THE
FINANCIAL ENVIRONMENT. IT'S A
LITTLE BIT DIFFERENT THAN WHEN
WE TOOK OFFICE. WE WERE COMING
IN OFF THE HEELS OF A GREAT
RECESSION. WE COSTLY WHO HERE
FROM THE CLASSES AHEAD OF US.
HAVE HAD TO SLEEP HERE ALL
NIGHT HOW TO HOW TO MAKE
DEVASTATING CUTS TO OUR SOCIAL
SAFETY NET TO HEALTH CARE TO
DDT CAL FRESH CAL WORKS EVERY
SINGLE PROGRAM. THE PEOPLE RELY
ON. IN THEIR DAILY LIVES JUST
TO GET THROUGH. EVERY DAY. AND
WHILE WE COULD BE SAVING MORE
WE STARTED THAT PARTICULAR YEAR
WITH RESERVE. ZERO THE PREVIOUS
SPEAKER SAID THIS BUDGET WAS
GREAT BECAUSE WE'RE BROKE WE'RE
NO LONGER DEFICIT WE ARE JUST
BROKE. AND WE WERE THE ONES OUR
CLASS WAS THE ONES WE PUT THE
RAINY DAY. FUND ON THE BALLOT.
WE HAD THIS AWKWARD BILLION
DOLLAR AFTER BILLION DOLLAR
AFTER BILLION DOLLAR AND THIS
IS ALL THE SAME TIME WHEN WE
WOULD HEAR FROM ALL THOSE
CONSTITUENCIES. BETTER STILL
RAINING OUTSIDE YOUR IT'S GREAT
THAT YOU'RE PUTTING MONEY INTO
THIS RAINY DAY FUND BUT YOU
KNOW. FOR THE DD FAMILIES IT'S
STILL RAINING. FOR FAMILIES
THAT DON'T HAVE HEALTH CARE YOU
KNOW WHAT IT'S STILL RAINING.
FOR FAMILIES I COULDN'T GET THE
CHILD CARE. GUESS WHAT. THEY
NEED HELP RIGHT NOW. FULL LIKE
EVERY BUDGET. WE WANT TO MAKE
SURE THAT WE ARE DOING WHAT IS
RIGHT FISCALLY IN BEING
COMPLETELY FISCALLY
RESPONSIBLE. WE ALSO HAVE TO
REMEMBER GOVERNMENT'S PRIMARY
JOB WHICH IS TO HELP THOSE MOST
IN NEED. THIS YEAR WHILE THE
STATE HAS A BUDGET SURPLUS
WE'VE ALL HAD A PRETTY AWFUL
YEAR. OUR COMMUNITIES HAVE HAD
A VERY VERY TOUGH YEAR. SO THIS
BUDGET RECOGNIZES ALL THE HELP
THAT EACH AND EVERY SINGLE ONE
OF OUR RESIDENTS ARE
COMMUNITIES AND OUR FAMILIES
NEED AT THIS TIME. IT'S HELP
FOR THE BUSINESSES THAT HAVE
STRUGGLED TO STAY OPEN DURING
THIS PANDEMIC. IT'S HELP FOR
THE FAMILIES THAT HAVEN'T BEEN
ABLE TO GO BACK TO WORK BECAUSE
THEY DON'T HAVE CHILD CARE.
IT'S HELP. FOR FAMILIES WHO ARE
HOMELESS AND HOUSED AND FED.
BEFORE THIS PANDEMIC MADE IT
EVEN WORSE. SO OUR JOB AS A
BODY IS TO DELIBERATE INTIMATE.
A DECISION THAT I REALLY DO
APPRECIATE THIS ROBUST
DELIBERATION THE IDEAS THAT WE
HAVE TALKED ABOUT THAT IS
REALLY OUR JOB AS THE
LEGISLATURE TO REPRESENT ALL
THE DIFFERENT. POINTS OF USE.
BUT LET ME TELL YOU WHEN YOU GO
HOME. AND YOU EACH ONE OF YOU
TO GO HOME TO YOUR COMMUNITY TO
TALK ABOUT THIS BUDGET. THERE
IS A LOT TO BE PROUD OF THERE'S
A LOT TO TALK ABOUT YOU WILL BE
DOING. A LOT TO CHANGE OUR
LIVES AND EACH AND EVERY SINGLE
ONE OF YOUR RESIDENCE. WITH
THAT I RESPECTFULLY ASK HER AYE
VOTE ON AB ONE TWENTY.
FIGURATION TANK. AND WITH THAT
CORPORAL OF THE ROLE. ALL
MEMBERS OF THE OUT OF. ALL
MEMBERS THE DESIRE TO VOTE. ALL
MEMBERS OF. YOUR DESIRE TO VOTE.
THE CLERK WILL. CLOSER ROLE.
TIED UP. I FIFTY SEVEN KNOWS
FIFTEEN SENATE AMENDMENTS ARE
CONCURRED IN. MEMBERS WE ARE
MOVING TO ASSEMBLY. THIRD
READING. FILE ITEMS TEN THROUGH
THIRTEEN PASS RETAIN. WE ARE
MOVING TO HAVE THIS
BOERNER HORVATH TAKE UP HER
RESOLUTION THIS IS FILE ITEM
FOURTEEN. AJ ARE. FOURTEEN I
MISS BOERNER HORVATH CORPORATE
IMAGE JOINT RESOLUTION FOURTEEN
BY ASSEMBLY MEMBER
BOERNER HORVATH BOTH OF HIS I
DON'T NINE MS BERMAN YES MISTER
SPEAKER MEMBERS AG ARE FOURTEEN
HONORS THE FORTY NINTH
ANNIVERSARY OF TITLE NINE
PROTECTIONS AGAINST SEX BASED
DISCRIMINATION IN OUR SCHOOLS I
WOULD URGE CALIFORNIA TO
CONTINUE TO WORK TOGETHER TO
ACHIEVE GOALS A MORE EQUAL
OPPORTUNITIES FOR YOU. TITLE
NINE IS A CIVIL RIGHTS LAW THAT
ALL ELEMENTARY SECONDARY SCHOOL
DISTRICTS COLLEGES AND
UNIVERSITIES RECEIVING FEDERAL
FUNDING MUST COMPLY WITH THE
LAWS INCLUDE CRITICAL AND
FOSTERING THE SUCCESS OF YOUNG
WOMAN FOR THE PAST FORTY NINE
YEARS. THESE PROTECTIONS ALSO
ALLOWED OUR STUDENTS TO THRIVE
AFTER THE ATHLETIC ACCESS IS
ALSO BEEN RECOGNIZED AS A SEX
SUCCESS OF TITLE NINE AND AS OF
TWENTY SEVENTEEN HIGH SCHOOL
ATHLETICS PARTICIPATION RATES
FOR GIRLS INCREASED BY MORE
THAN 1000% SINCE THE LAW PASSED
IN NINETEEN SEVENTY TWO. THE
PROMISE OF TITLE NINE IS THAT
IT GUARANTEES EDUCATIONAL
EQUITY FOR EVERYONE REGARDLESS%
OF SEX GENDER IDENTITY OR
GENDER EXPRESSION WELL THIS
LAWS INCREASED OPPORTUNITIES
FOR GIRLS AND WOMEN IN ACADEMIC
SPORTS AND OTHER EDUCATIONAL
ACTIVITIES IT IS NOT YET
ACHIEVED ITS GOAL OF FULL
EQUALITY. AG ARE FOURTEEN
RECOGNIZES THE STRIDES THAT
WE'VE MADE SINCE TITLE NINE HAS
BECOME LAW AND URGES US TO
CONTINUE TO FIGHT FOR EQUAL
OPPORTUNITIES. I RESPECTFULLY
ASK FOR ANOTHER. THANK YOU IS
BERNARDA. SAYING NO DISCUSSION
DEBATE ON THE H. A R. THIS
PURPOSE WOULD YOU LIKE TO
AUTHORS. IS BOERNER HORVATH IS
ASKING THAT THE FIRST ROLE BE
OPEN FOR CO AUTHORS ON THE
RESOLUTION CARPOOL OVER THE
ROLE. THIS IS FOR A CO AUTHORS
ON H. A R. FOURTEEN THIS IS CO
AUTHORS. ON THE RESOLUTION.
THIS IS FOR CO AUTHORS. CLERK
WILL. CLOSER ALL THERE ARE
FIFTY NINE CO AUTHORS THIS IS
AN AJ ARE THEREFORE WE WILL
TAKE A ROLL CALL VOTE. CRACKLE
OF THE ROLE. MEMBERS WHO DESIRE.
TO ALL MEMBERS VOTERS THAT A
VOTE. CLARK WELL. CLOSER ROLE
TELL YOU THE I. SIXTY THREE NO
ZERO. THAT RESOLUTIONS ADOPTED
MOVING TO FILE OUT OF FIFTEEN
THIS IS A C. R. EIGHTY THREE BY
MR MCCARTY CARBURY. ASSEMBLY
CONCURRENT RESOLUTION EIGHTY
THREE BY ASSEMBLY. THANK YOU
MISTER SPEAKER THIS IS THE DAY
THAT WE AS THE STATE ASSEMBLY
GET TO CELEBRATE LOVING DAY.
THIS WEEKEND WAS THE FIFTY
FOURTH ANNIVERSARY OF THE
FAMOUS LOVING DECISION WHICH
ESSENTIALLY ALLOWED INTER
RACIAL MARRIAGES IN OUR NATION
IT'S HARD TO BELIEVE THAT THIS
WAS THE LAW OF THE LAND FIVE
DECADES AGO AND THIS IS ALWAYS
AN IMPORTANT ISSUE TO TALK
ABOUT BUT A SPECIALLY AFTER
LAST YEAR WE'VE TALKED ABOUT
OUR RACIAL RECONCILIATION OF
OUR LAWS. THIS IS ONE THAT WE
SHOULD ALWAYS REMEMBER I
CERTAINLY THE DAYS TODAY THEIR
MISSION IS TO FIGHT RACIAL
PREJUDICE PROMOTE TOLERANCE AND
FOSTER A SUPPORTIVE
MULTICULTURAL SOCIETY BUT A
BOILS DOWN TOO MANY DECADES AGO
THE PEOPLE IN OUR STATE AND OUR
COUNTRY. COULDN'T GET MARRIED
AND COULDN'T LOVE THE ONES THAT
BUT THEY THEY WANTED TO AND
CERTAINLY PEOPLE ON THIS FLOOR
INCLUDING MYSELF ARE LOVING
KIDS I WAS A PRODUCT OF
INTERRACIAL MARRIAGE IN THE
LATE NINETEEN SIXTIES WHEN MY
PARENTS MET. WERE IN VIRGINIA
THREE YEARS EARLIER IT WOULD
HAVE BEEN LAWFUL FOR THEM TO BE
MARRIED HAVE A CHILD ME I WAS
BORN IN WASHING DC JUST OUTSIDE
OF THE PLACE WHERE THIS WAS THE
LAW OF THE LAND AND SO THIS IS
A VERY PERSONAL ISSUE FOR I
KNOW I'M A MEMBER OF A NUMBER
OF MEMBERS ON THIS FLOOR.
EITHER LOVING KIDS WHO HAVE OR
HAVE HAD LOVING KIDS AND BUT
FOR THIS A FAMOUS COURT
DECISION WE WOULDN'T BE HERE
TODAY WE KNOW ABOUT ITS
SIGNIFICANCE AND ITS IMPACT.
AND JUST WANTED TO NOTE THAT.
RICHARD LOVING TOLD THE COURT
THAT HE JUST WANTS HIS WIFE TO
KNOW THAT HE LOVES HER. AND
THEIR NAME HAPPEN TO BE LOVING
OF COURSE AND THAT OF COURSE
MAKES THE STORY SO ENDEARING
BUT THIS HAS A FOOTPRINT IN
CALIFORNIA HISTORY AS WELL.
THIS WAS BASED UPON DECISION OF
INJURY OPERATE AS A MEXICAN
AMERICAN AND SYLVESTER DAVIS AN
AFRICAN AMERICAN WHO TEN YEARS
EARLIER ALSO FOUGHT THE SYSTEM
AND TRY TO MAKE SURE THEY HAD A
CHANCE TO BE MARRIED AND LATER
ON DECADES LATER THIS BECAME
PART. OF THE FAMOUS SUPREME
COURT DECISION IN IN TWENTY
FIFTEEN TO LEGALIZE LGBT
MARRIAGES AGAIN MISTER SPEAKER
MEMBERS I ASK THAT WE RECOGNIZE
AND HONOR THE FIFTY FOURTH
ANNIVERSARY ELEVEN DAY THANK
YOU. THANK YOU MR MCCARTY
MISTER LOWE YOU ARE RECOGNIZED.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH MISTER
SPEAKER COLLEAGUES I THINK THE
OUR COLLEAGUE FROM SACRAMENTO
FOR BRING THIS FORWARD. AS A
RECOGNITION AS A REMINDER I
RISE AS THE CHAIR OF THE
CALIFORNIA LGBT LEGISLATIVE
CAUCUS AND OF COURSE IN THE
MONTH OF JUNE. AS WE CELEBRATE
PRIDE MONTH WE TO KNOW ABOUT
THE CHALLENGE OF BEING ACCUSED
ABOUT THE DETERIORATION OF. THE
INSTITUTION OF MARRIAGE AND OF
COURSE THE OPPORTUNITY TO MARRY
THE PERSON THAT WE LOVE AND SO
COURSE WE STAND IN SOLIDARITY.
AND THANK THE MEMBER FOR
HELPING US RECOGNIZE THIS
OCCASION AS WE- CELEBRATE BUT
ALSO WORK HARD TO MAKE SURE
THAT FUTURE GENERATIONS DO NOT
TAKE THIS FOR GRANTED. THANK
YOU MR LOW SEEING NO OTHER
MEMBERS. SEEKING RECOGNITION MR
MCCARTY WOULD YOU LIKE CO
AUTHORS. FIRST ROLE THE OPEN
FOR CO AUTHORS CORPORAL. THIS
IS FOR CO AUTHORS ON THE
RESOLUTION CO AUTHORS ON ACR.
EIGHTY THREE THIS IS FOR CO
AUTHORS. WELL. CLOSE ROLE THERE
ARE SIXTY EIGHT CO AUTHORS
ADDED WITHOUT OBJECTION WE MAY
TAKE A VOICE VOTE ON THE
RESOLUTION ALL THOSE IN FAVOR
SAY AYE AYE OPPOSED SAY NAY.
YES HAVE IT THE RESOLUTION. IS
ADOPTED. MEMBERS IN THE ABSENCE
OF OBJECTION WE WILL NOW MOVE
TO PREVIOUSLY ANNOUNCED THE
GERMANS IN MEMORY. AVERAGE
PLEASE TAKE YOUR CONVERSATIONS
OFF OF THE FLOOR. FOR EACH
REMAINING YOUR SEATS MEMBERS.
THE FOLLOWING MEMBERS OR
GREATER PREPARATION TO SPEAK ON
A GERMAN IN MEMORY. MEMBERS
PLEASE GIVE YOUR ATTENTION TO
MISS WICKS MISS WICKS YOU ARE
RECOGNIZED FOR YOUR GERMAN IN
MEMORY. THANK YOU THANK YOU
MISTER SPEAKER. MEMBERS TODAY
WE JOIN IN THE MEMORY OF
NINETEEN YEAR OLD DIXIE LEWIS
AND TWENTY YEAR OLD RUSSELL'S
TO BERKELEY HIGH GRADUATE
STUDENT ATHLETES AND COMMUNITY
MEMBERS WHO PASSED AWAY MAY
TWENTY FIFTH IN A TRAGIC CAR
ACCIDENT IN TAHOE. THE YOUNG
COUPLE HAD SUCH PROMISING
FUTURES AHEAD OF THEM AND WE'RE
LIVING FULL AND HAPPY LIVES
WHEN THEIR- LIVES WERE CUT VERY
SHORT. DIXIE GRADUATED FROM
BERKELEY HIGH IN TWENTY TWENTY
AND COMPLETED HER FRESHMAN YEAR
AT POMONA COLLEGE. WHERE SHE
PLAYED SOFTBALL AND HOPE TO
MAJOR IN NEUROSCIENCE SHE WAS
THE DAUGHTER OF BESTSELLING
AUTHOR MICHAEL LEWIS WHO
RECENTLY PUBLISHED THE
PREMONITION OF PANDEMIC STORY.
AND HAVE A T SOREN A
PHOTOGRAPHER AND FORMER
POLITICAL CORRESPONDENT FOR MTV.
SHE WAS LOVED BY HER PARENTS
HER BOYFRIEND ROSS WITH HIM SHE
DIED. BROTHER WALKER AND SISTER
QUINN WHO WILL CONTINUE TO KEEP
HER MEMORY ALIVE IN HER ABSENCE
DIXIE WANTED NOTHING MORE TO BE
THAN TO BE A DEMONIC TO BE ON
HOMEOWNERS CAMPUS AND PLAY ON
THE SOFTBALL. FIELD WITH HER
FRIENDS HER ATHLETICISM QUICKLY
DREW ATTENTION ON THE FIELD
WELL HER WARM SPIRIT POSITIVE
ENERGY AND BIG SMILE WON
EVERYONE'S HEARTS. SHE WAS
BELOVED BY HER PROMOTED
TEAMMATES AND COACH FERGUSON.
HOME SHE TRAINED WITH
THROUGHOUT THE STATE'S LOCKED
DOWN. THEIR TEAM IS HEARTBROKEN
BY DIXIE'S LOSS. AND A POSITIVE
IMPACT. ON THEIR LIVES WILL
FOREVER BE WITH THE TEAM. ROSS
WHO PLAYED SOCCER FOR MUCH OF
HIS LIFE WAS A MEMBER OF THE
BERKELEY HIGH TWO TIME NORTH
COAST CHAMPIONSHIP SOCCER TEAM.
HE JUST FINISHED HIS SECOND
YEAR CAL POLY POMONA WHERE HE
WAS STUDYING KINESIOLOGY. ROSS
WAS UNAPOLOGETICALLY UNIQUE HE
WAS ALWAYS AUTHENTICALLY
HIMSELF AND NEVER CHANGE FOR
ANYONE OR ANYTHING. A FORMER
SOCCER COACH. JT THOMAS
DESCRIBED HIM AS QUOTE A FIERCE
COMPETITOR WITH A CONSTANT
QUOTE SPARKLE IN HIS EYE HE WAS
SOLELY DRIVEN AND FOUGHT HARD
FOR WHAT HE LOVES HE HAD AN
INFECTIOUS WAY MAKING YOU FEEL
WELCOME WITHOUT JUDGMENT HIS
FRIENDS SAY. THERE IS NOT A
SINGLE PERSON IN THE WORLD HE
DID NOT LIKE HIM WITH THE
PASSING OF ROCKS WITH THE
PASSING OF ROSS AND DIXIE THEIR
FAMILIES LOST A BELOVED SON AND
DAUGHTER THEIR PEERS LOST A
DEVOTED FRIEND AND THE BERKELEY
COMMUNITY LOST TWO PROMISING.
YOUNG FRIENDS WHO WERE ON THEIR
WAY TO DO GREAT THINGS IN LIFE
YOUNG PEOPLE LIKE THEM ARE OUR
FUTURE AND THERE'S WAS TAKEN
AWAY FAR TOO SOON I ASK THAT
THIS BODY ADJOURNMENT MEMORY.
TAKING THIS WICKS THANK YOU
MEMBERS PLEASE BRING THE NAMES
OF THE DEATHS REPORTED IN THE
JOURNAL ALL REQUESTED JOURNAL
MEMORIES WILL BE DEEMED READ.
AND PRINTED IN THE JOURNAL. WE
TO ANNOUNCEMENTS. MEMBERS MR
FRAZIER INVITES MEMBERS TO PICK
UP A COPY AND THE MEMBERS
LOUNGE. THAT'S A COOKIE AND A
MEMBERS LOUNGE FOR MISTER
FRAZIER. SESSION SCHEDULE IS AS
FOLLOWS TUESDAY JUNE FIFTEENTH
CHECK IN SESSION WEDNESDAY JUNE
SIXTEENTH CHECK IN SESSION.
THURSDAY JUNE SEVENTEENTH FLOOR
SESSION IS AT NINE AM ALL OTHER
ITEMS REMAINING WILL BE PASSED
TO RETAIN ALL MOTION SHALL BE
CONTINUE. SEEING HEARING OR FOR
THE BUSINESS I'M READY TO
ENTERTAIN A MOTION TO ADJOURN
MR BERMAN MOVES MISTER FLORA
SECONDS THAT THIS HOUSE STANDS
ADJOURNED UNTIL THURSDAY JUNE
SEVENTEENTH AT NINE AM. AND THE
QUORUM CALL IS LIFTED.